hg welds is a name that is synonymous
with the creation of what we now know as
science fiction he effectively invented
the subgenre of alien invasion he coined
the now ubiquitous terms time machine
heat ray and even disputably the new
world order but what most people don't
know about wells is that although today
he is predominantly known for his
science fiction his career as a sci-fi
author was pretty short wells wrote
dozens of novels most of which weren't
even science fiction but despite the
relatively few number of science fiction
works he wrote in comparison to his vest
wells was an influential thinker not
just for the genre of science fiction
but for science's relationship to the
culture at large
herbert george wells the son of servants
turned shopkeepers escaped
apprenticeships in draper shops to
become a pupil teacher at midhurst
grammar school in the south of england a
scholarship propelled him to what is now
imperial college london where he studied
biology under champion of darwinism t.h
huxley grandfather of brave new world
author eldest huxley graduating in 1890
but within a few years he transitioned
to writing and quickly became hugely
popular with people from all
demographics sort of the stephen king of
his day but he was particularly popular
with the working class you love to see
it
according to columbia university
professor of english sarah cole he had
many readers among working people coming
in second in the list of favorite
novelists pulled by the workers
education association
we uh
in
1936. put a hidden that note
of course like half of the authors we
cover our boy was not without his fused
to this day people sometimes confused
the works of wells with his contemporary
jules verne
wells was irritated by this comparison
of his work to verns and the feeling was
mutual then there was george orwell my
boy whom wells feuded a lot with later
in life despite their similar politics
they had an idea of what the end should
be but really disagreed on the means and
on the nature of humanity in general
orwell's gripe was that welles naively
believed in the natural progression of
scientific progress as inevitably
leading to a better world
orwell was right guys he knew that
twitter was going to come and destroy
everything and facebook and instagram
get off social media but keep watching
youtube and it's lit videos on pbs
storied orwell implied that wells was a
dusty old victorian who was a relic of a
bygone era in the listener in march of
1942.
wells fired off a letter in response to
orwell that very week which has
regrettably been lost to time except for
this bit
i didn't say that at all read my earlier
works you sh
was there anyone orwell didn't beef with
and also that would have been an
excellent tweet
wells was one of the earliest major
english fiction writers to be a trained
scientist his approach to science
fiction or scientific romance as he
called it was kept rooted in reality
only include one far-flung concept and
keep that concept rooted in the real
world
i.e the time machine is told from the
point of view of the time traveler
talking to his friends after he got back
from his adventure
in his future earth there's just humans
no aliens no robots haven't taken over
humanity just humans and that's the
thing we're going to explore with our
time machine there is generally only one
thing per novel invisibility aliens time
travel etc so there's no smash up here
no cowboys versus aliens or abraham
lincoln vampire hunter but much of wells
influence were the archetypes and tropes
he helped popularize within science
fiction take the invisible man great
movie again a fairly simple story a
scientist invents a way to change your
human body's refractive index to that of
air so that it neither absorbs nor
reflects light rendering him invisible
the story isn't so much about the man's
adventures but what this seemingly
innocuous superpower brings out in him
invisible man was influential less
because of its focus on technology
although welles's focus on the
scientific house was important to him
but more the thought experiment of what
a person would do if they could escape
accountability and was his first
scientific romance the time machine the
protagonist known only as the time
traveler travels to a future where man
has evolved into two distinct species
murlocs and eloy we'll get into that
later
this book was so wildly popular it
started an entire sub-genre that of time
travel and also coined the term
time machine which you never think
needed to be coined but there he did it
according to professor of english at
robert morris university sylvia pambukin
while he does not innovate in using time
travel or evolutionary concepts wells
develops important tropes that open the
genre to new possibilities wells
introduces machinery to this genre and
explores the role of technology in the
genre he also innovates in his
presentation of the time traveler
himself which has far-reaching
implications both in wells's own work
and in the genre as a whole the isle of
doctor moreau draws a lot from
frankenstein but also builds on that
trope
moreau helped codify mary shelley's mad
scientist as a recurrent figure in
science fiction but takes it a step
further by making him no longer
horrified by his creations but excited
by them this was a particular character
archetype in the 50s and 60s and remains
extremely popular to this day
right morty
according to professor jay clayton dr
moreau draws a powerful portrait of an
irresponsible scientist and it directly
anticipates contemporary concerns about
the creation of chimeras but these are
not the only ways welles novel can
contribute to the public policy debate
in the early 19th century there was
nothing like today's disciplinary
structures for most of the 19th century
discipline based expertise was not the
primary way a savant gave influence in
the public sphere
much of the frustration of early
advocates of disciplinarity such as
charles babbage
then there is the war of the worlds
arguably wells's most influential work
war of the world started an entire
subgenre which remains very popular
alien invasion
but also inspired the most well-known
adaptations of wells's work from orson
welles's no relation 1938 audio drama
that was so realistic listers thought it
was happening for real to the 1953 film
adaptation to steven spielberg's 2005
adaptation which has a really great
first half
according to cultural historian john
higgs a book like the war of the worlds
inspired every one of the thousands of
alien invasion stories that followed it
burned its way into the psyche of
mankind and changed us all forever
but war of the worlds didn't come from
nowhere it also came out of a then
popular genre in britain called invasion
literature
which sprang from the anxiety that those
uppity prussians might come for britain
next after they invaded france in the
1870s
wells combined this genre of literature
with the also popular idea of
intelligent aliens specifically from
mars using it to put a mirror to british
colonialism according to university of
dundee professor keith williams
the war of the worlds elaborated the
possibility of this emerging alien gaze
to allow contemporary britain to look
long and hard itself and the ethics of
its foreign policy from the vantage
point of another species a nightmare
version of the colonial other integral
to its expansionist ideology the
critique of colonialism in war of the
worlds isn't subtext either it's text in
the first chapter of war of the worlds
well states
and before we judge of them too harshly
we must remember what ruthless and utter
destruction our own species has wrought
the tasmanians in spite of their human
likeness
were entirely swept out of existence in
a war of extermination waged by european
immigrants in the space of 50 years are
we such apostles of mercy as to complain
at the martians ward in the same spirit
this basic thought experiment has
remained a staple of alien invasion
literature to this day from the
indigenous suffocation of aliens and
narratives where humans are the
colonizers to the idea of firepower we
can't match in which humans are the
colonized in 1898 britain was still the
most powerful imperial power on the
planet so victorian british minds were
blown by this reversal of roles this
idea that somewhere out there there may
be a race of beings more powerful than
the british
according to wells biographer and former
british labour party leader michael
foote wells planned to write a book that
would show the english what it would be
like to be overtaken by a race more
developed better armed and even more
ruthlessly genocidal than themselves to
the martians he wrote in the
introduction to the war of the worlds we
men the creatures who inhabit this earth
must be to them at least as alien and
lowly as are the monkeys and lemurs to
us
and we can't talk about these 19th
century thought leaders without talking
about
eugenics
eugenics was a topic that wells had
mixed feelings on in edwardian britain
eugenics was the new hotness but though
wells didn't want to discount the theory
completely he also had his doubts
though he did have an affair with
margaret sanger among many many other
women because h.g wells
liked to smash for one thing he was
never on board with positive eugenics or
the idea that we can breed or
genetically engineer a superior human in
1904 responding to francis galton
co-founder of eugenics well said i
believe that now and always the
conscious selection of the best for
reproduction will be impossible that to
propose it is to display a fundamental
misunderstanding of what individuality
implies that said wells also said it is
in the sterilization of failure and not
in the selection of success for breeding
that the possibility of an improvement
of the human stock lies
so
that's a whole yikes
in other words he wasn't sold on
positive eugenics but he wasn't against
negative eugenics or the idea that we
can breed out certain traits or genetic
defects
and that's its own gross can of worms so
how does this apply to his fiction so
the isle of dr moreau is more concerned
with the ethics of genetic engineering
than the implications of eugenics which
is about breeding a superior human
but what about the time machine which
some have called a love letter to
eugenics
we go
in the time machine humanity has evolved
into two distinct species the murlocs
and the eloy the eloy are these elfin
childlike day walkers that just kind of
have fun and vibe all day they're
basically like the trolls in troll
then there are the murlocs who live
underground and only come out at night
and like in the movie trolls turns out
that they eat the eloy
like the bergens and trolls
so how did these two humanities come to
be
in effect the eloy are descendants of
the bourgeoisie and the morocco are
descendants of the proletariat
why
the murlocs eat the rich
the time traveler describes it thus so
in the end above ground you must have
the haves pursuing pleasure and comfort
and beauty and below ground the
have-nots the workers getting
continually adapted to the conditions of
their labor according to pambukin the
sublime landscapes of the future and the
events of 802
701 highlight the vast sweep and power
of evolution
and the small time-bound achievements of
humanity a somewhat distressing
conclusion because it reverses the
popular idea that science can influence
evolution and produce a better society a
key concept of social darwinism eugenics
and several earlier time travel
narratives welles's fiction reflected
welles's own conflicting ideas on
science and progress he demonstrates a
belief that science could better
humanity while cautioning that
betterment thanks to technology is not
inevitable there is plenty that could
derail that future widening income
inequality and class division for
instance if it's not obvious wells like
orwell was a socialist but he wasn't a
marxist reason being marx believed that
a violent class war between the
bourgeoisie and the proletariat was
inevitable
and in russia well
clearly marx was not wrong completely
but wells believed that through science
and rationality eventually we could all
just get along
maybe the means of production were the
friends we made along the way
but that didn't mean that this future
was inevitable in the words of the time
traveler at first proceeding from the
problems of our own age it seemed clear
as daylight to me that the gradual
widening of the present merely temporary
and social difference between the
capitalists and the laborer
was the key to the whole position
no doubt it will seem grotesque enough
to you and wildly incredible and yet
even now there are existing
circumstances to point that way
welles's scientific romance was usually
influential not just in fiction but in
the real world and also predicted
technologies that were decades if not
more than a century out the war of the
worlds inspired robert goddard inventor
of the liquid field rocket whose
research led to nasa's apollo program to
devote his life to space travel wells
1914 novel the world set free predicted
the atomic bomb drawing on and
subsequently influencing chemists
frederick saudi's work on radioactivity
and influencing physicist leo silard in
his work on the neutron chain reaction
and with regard to dr moreau's creations
according to clayton the scientific
breakthrough wells imagined in 1896
has become a reality in 2006
in the last few years the questions
raised by the creation of intraspecies
hybrids
xenotransplants and chimeras have become
pressing enough to prompt the institute
of medicine iom to issue guidelines
covering the ethical constraints on such
research
he even predicted something like
wikipedia in an address to the royal
institute in 1936 on the world
encyclopedia or world brain he described
it as such the mental background of
every intelligent man in the world it
should be alive and growing and changing
continually under a vision extension and
replacement from the original thinkers
in the world everywhere
every university and research
institution should feed it
every fresh mind should be brought into
contact with its standing editorial
organization its contents would be the
standard source of material for the
instructional side of school and college
work for the verification of facts and
the testing of statements everywhere in
the world well saw science fiction as a
genre not only in conversation with
science but in conversation with itself
according to former vice president of
the h.g wells society brian aldis within
the domain of scientific romance he
managed three unique achievements he
elevated the freak event a visit to the
moon a invasion from another planet into
an artistic whole
in consequence he greatly expanded the
scope and power of such imaginings and
he brought to the genre a popularity and
a distinctness from other genres which
it has never lost since despite the
blunders of many following his wake
h.g wells helped create and popularize
tools that allow us to envision all
sorts of futures good and bad but one
thing is for sure if you see an alien
sneeze on it
[Music]
you